Oh oh my god what is that
I love oxtail I grew up eating axle
actually I was probably one of the most
delicious meats there is out there
I could eat breakfast every meal of
every day waffles pancakes bacon sausage
butter is the most versatile ingredient
of all time you can put it on stuff you
can eat it plain it's delicious its
nutritious
I don't know else to say about it it's
amazing
so I asked haven't oXXO prepared by a
chef I'm excited to try it I was told
that I'm coming here to try my favorite
food made by a wonderful chef but I'm
almost positive that that is not the
case and I've been bamboozled
so I just
this is getting kinky real fast oh boy I
don't want to do fine fold it like this
oh it's cold it is very cold
Oh No I really have to taste these these
are popsicles I'm trying I said a
popsicle oh that's delicious
no I don't taste anything in this I'm
not gonna bite this yeah this is
disgusting good okay this is my favorite
cuz this is delicious oh that's
disgusting that is not mine that
actually doesn't taste bad this tastes
like some form of barbecue dominican
republic we grabbed on the leftovers and
we give it to the pigs that's what it
tastes like
oh it's almost sweet like Thai food is
this like curry isn't a doctor what no
I'm not
whatever that is no this is dinner
oh that texture Oh oh my god what is
that that's not pleasant
that's disgusting this one's definitely
austere dinasty
I don't know why I took another buyer
that this tastes like garlic this tastes
Italian yeah you Ryan
that's all I want to say well they look
beautiful they look way better than I
expected this smells like dog food
you serious I don't wish this on my
worst enemy I think I did terribly you
want to know why because this is
[ __ ] how'd that God did know how do
I think you did you did orrible this is
not what I did I tried this well if it's
edible bring it on
Yomi hey okay this isn't terrible this
one I couldn't even get past the smell
and this didn't taste like anything but
that again it's just butter I'm gonna
make this and eat this all summer
because it's nice and cool and delicious
and I'm a fan butter the pancakes that
didn't make it taste better
where's the Ruach still coming out
though there isn't any huh
okay thank you we got the hell out of
here would you like yeah that's it I
like let's take a little bit of extra
oxtail rice and being straight up it is
in the refrigerator so that way you can
actually have
[Music]